[Як відреагувало громадянське суспільство
на пандемію?]
[Ukraїner
на карантині]
[Виготовлення засобів захисту]
Добрий день! Мене звати Оля, я шию маски.
У цьому мені допомагає моя доця Анна.
Нещодавно ми переїхали до Львова з Миколаєва.
Чоловіка перевели по службі,
і ми, власне, всі разом переїхали.
Щойно переїхали — почався карантин.
Як і всі свідомі українці, ми слідкуємо за подіями
в країні, і слідкуємо за ситуацією.
Тут триває наш процес виробництва.
За час карантину ми виготовили вже
більше десяти тисяч захисних екранів.
Також наша команда інженерів працює над
розробкою апарату штучної вентиляції легень.
Також ми зараз друкуємо різні
перехідні клапани для інших майстерень,
які теж розробляють
апарати штучної вентиляції легень.
Всім привіт, мене звати Тетяна Кім.
Я дизайнер одягу, власник ательє і
викладач у власній школі крою та шиття.
Живу і творю у місті Кривий Ріг.
Як почався карантин, я вирішила,
що це найкращий час для відпочинку.
Для того, щоб провести час зі своїми дітьми.
Зазвичай я багато часу проводжу на роботі:
з ранку до вечора.
Але коли знайомі почали звертатися
один за одним по маски,
я зрозуміла, що в країні критично
не вистачає масок.
Тому зараз ми виготовляємо маски для обличчя
зі стовідсоткової бавовни.
Запропонувала дівчатам розмежувати
роботу таким чином,
щоб ми не порушували вимоги карантину.
Дівчата працюють у себе вдома,
я працюю тут в ательє сама.
Зробили пост в facebook.
Дівчата написали: «Якщо маєш фінансову змогу
купити маску, приходь — купуй.
Якщо не маєш такої можливості,
приходь — бери її безкоштовно.
Якщо маєш тканину, але не можеш пошити маску,
приходь, ми пошиємо її безкоштовно.
Люди, які купували партію 50 масок,
лишали їх у мене на мій власний розсуд.
Люди довіряли мені. Це дорого коштує,
коли людина тобі довіряє.
Перша партія — 25 масок — пішла родинам,
в яких виховуються діти з синдромом Дауна.
Друга партія пішла родинам,
де діти з розладом аутистичного спектру.
Потім — родини, чиї рідні загинули в АТО.
Зараз ми відшиваємо маски бійцям.
Ми маємо в наявності
також і багаторазові комбінезони.
Також є блакитні і сині [комбінезони],
до них у набір дають також бахіли.
Ми складаємо їх, по можливості, відповідно
до замовлень, більше і менше: три, п'ять, десять.
Потім маркуємо коробки,
і відправляємо замовнику.
Матеріал: два шари мікроволокна, вагою 30 грам,
і один шар мікроволокна,
вагою 60 грам на метр квадратний.
Скільки ми накроїли штук [масок] за тиждень?
За тиждень ми накроїли 10 тисяч [масок].
Десять тисяч.
Ми нашим цехом можемо шити
одну тисячу масок на день.
Це наша команда
по виготовленню захисних щитків:
моя дружина Лариса,
моя донька Антонія і Банячок.
Але Банячок нам не дуже допомагає,
він більше нам шкодить.
Першим ділом — треба зняти захисну плівку
з самого захисного скла.
Сьогодні ми уже виготовили
більше 300 захисних щитків.
Це все буде відправлено по всій Україні,
а також по області.
І хочу вам сказати, що таке виробництво
дало змогу нам
забезпечити майже всіх
івано-франківських медиків,
які зараз у прямому контакті з пацієнтами,
які мають підозру на коронавірусну інфекцію.
У баночці є сто мілілітрів [пероксиду водню],
сорок п'ять мілілітрів гліцерину,
двадцять [мілілітрів] ефірної лавандової олії.
Просто ось так [перемішати],
він [антисептик] потім собі настоюється.
Принцип роботи такого диспенсера,
або ось такого, теж дуже просто:
кілька разів треба прокачати,
кілька разів потиснули на руку і все,
і антисептик уже у вас на руках.
Як соціальний підприємець,
я займаюся пошиттям і розробкою речей
для передчасно народжених дітей,
тобто для дитячих реанімацій.
Ось такі масочки ми шиємо для лікарів,
а також для маленьких діток.
Такі масочки є тришаровими,
вони мають два захисні шари в середині,
і один — зверху, яскравий,
для того, щоб піднімати настрій,
якщо вони працюють у дитячому відділенні.
Дякую за увагу! До побачення!
Дякую! Бувай!
[Допомога медикам]
Команда Ротарі «Лучеськ» із міста Луцьк
презентує програму по пошиттю
і роздачі багаторазових масок
для найбільш вразливих верств населення.
І я також долучаюся до цієї програми.
Маленькими кроками йдемо до великої перемоги.
Будьте здорові, і бережіть себе!
Ми запустили з колегами ініціативу
«Кава для медика».
Ідея полягала в тому,
щоб залучити якомога більше малого бізнесу
для підтримки медиків і лікарів.
Так як малий бізнес дуже обмежений у фінансах,
і зараз на межі виживання,
але в кожного бізнесу, в кожній кав'ярні, підприємстві, магазині і так далі,
є запас продукції.
Наша ініціатива була в тому,
щоб поділитися оцим запасом з медиками.
Для цього ми сконтактувалися
з перевіреною організацією,
у нашому випадку
це був «Червоний Хрест України»,
і домовились про те, що ми частину
нашої продукції передаємо їм,
і вони розподіляють її на станції
швидкої допомоги у місті Київ,
і до Олександріївської лікарні, де зараз
знаходиться найбільше хворих на коронавірус.
Мене звуть Аня, і я живу у Дніпрі,
працюю тут випусковою редакторкою
локального журналу про культуру.
Цей журнал називається «Куст»,
і незважаючи на кризу,
яка особливо зачепила культурну сферу,
наше медіа продовжує жити.
Ми зробили проєкт,
який допоможе медикам нашої області.
Це сайт, на якому можна зробити
внесок у благодійний фонд «Кіддо»,
і за це отримати унікальний архів розмальовок
від класних художників із Дніпра.
У нашій редакції дуже важливо
говорити про те, що культура —
це не мистецтво заради мистецтва,
що вона може вирішувати і соціальні проблеми.
Я думаю, нам у зайвий раз вдалося це довести.
Після пандемії у світі дуже сильно зміниться ставлення до волонтерства.
Зараз стільки людей підключилося
до спільної справи, що питань
«А навіщо тобі це?», «А чому ти робиш
це без грошей?»  стане набагато менше.
Кожен з нас має прийняти рішення:
чи вийти на вулицю, чи залишитися вдома,
чи критикувати, чи просто допомогти.
Ми прийняли рішення допомагати тим,
чим ми можемо:
на зібрані кошти і на базі ресторану «Клеопатра»,
ми готуємо обіди, які відвозимо в лікарню,
також ми закупляли невелику кількість масок,
біля тисячі штук,
які теж роздали в лікарні.
Зараз я займаюсь координуванням напрямку психологічної підтримки
волонтерського руху StopCovid UA.
Навчаємо психологів-волонтерів
разом із кризовим колл-центром,
який був організований під час Майдану.
Ми зараз навчимо всіх наших волонтерів
кризовій консультації,
і в подальшому
ті самі психологи будуть продовжувати співпрацювати з цим кризовим центром,
для того, щоб допомагати їм
відповідати на дзвінки «гарячої» лінії.
Ми сьогодні, нарешті, підписали договір
з великою українською страховою компанією,
якою застрахували медиків швидкої
медичної допомоги і інфекційної лікарні.
І сьогодні цей договір уже набирає чинності.
Ми застрахували медиків
на лікування від COVID-19 на три місяці,
тобто якщо медик захворіє,
він одразу може отримувати ліки в аптеках,
не витрачаючи свої кошти до 25 тисяч гривень.
Оскільки більшість наших бізнес-активностей
перейшло в онлайн-формат,
у нас є трішки фізичного часу,
ми просто взяли та почали допомагати лікарням.
Ми почали з логістики лікарів,
далі почали допомагати з забезпеченням
засобів [індивідуального захисту].
Наразі ми продовжуємо.
Дуже крута ідея — допомагати зараз тим,
хто умовно знаходиться на передовій:
це лікарям і медичному персоналу.
Плануємо розмістити на наших сайтах доставок
таку позицію, як піца «Нагодуй лікаря».
Єдине, що для того, щоб це було все законно,
нам необхідно укласти угоду
з благочинним фондом.
Зараз відгукнувся фонд «Крила надії».
Щоб ми ті кошти перераховували
благочинному фонду,
а він, відповідно, закуповував на ці кошти страви.
Ми охопили більше, ніж дев'ять лікарень,
підприємців — до двадцяти — це точно.
Кожного дня ми забезпечуємо
мінімум десять обідів на кожну лікарню.
Мені здається, що у такий час для країни,
кожен має знайти те, в чому він буде корисним.
Хтось працює, і робить так,
щоб наша економіка не зупинялася,
хтось вдома виховує своїх дітей,
і це також важливо,
але ми вирішили,
що ми будемо допомагати медикам.
Фонд «Рідні» об'єднав бізнес:
у них є кілька бізнес-партнерів,
які, за допомогою своїх фінансових ресурсів,
дали змогу купити обладнання для лікарень.
[Транспорт для медиків]
У зв'язку з карантином...
— Руки дуже дивно так виглядають?
—Ні.
— Ні? Нормально?
— Так.
Може краще якось так? Або так?
Без різниці.
Давай! Розкажи людям,
чим ти займаєшся на карантині.
Та давай уже кажи!
Давай заново!
Зараз, у зв'язку з карантином,
я багато їм, багато сплю та багато працюю.
Під час карантину я
створив сервіс «Підвези медика»,
який знаходиться за адресою cometa.in.ua.
І його завдання, в принципі просте, —
це допомогти медичним працівникам
дістатись до своїх робочих місць.
От, день життя волонтера продовжується:
це у нас 240 масочок
і 35 захисних закритих окулярів для медиків.
Ранок у будні починається зазвичай десь о шостій,
буває раніше.
А ось, наприклад, зараз субота,
і сьогодні ранок почався о сьомій
з розвезення медиків на роботу
і з роботи — кого як:
хто з доби їде, хто — навпаки.
Найголовніше робоче місце, —
це, насправді, мотоцикл,
тому що саме на мотоциклі волонтери MotoHelp
реагують на швидку допомогу,
саме на мотоциклах ми
перевозимо компоненти донорської крові,
саме на мотоциклах ми, навіть,
перевозимо медичних співробітників.
І це вже 12 років.
Компанія «Авіс-Україна» займається
прокатом і лізингом автомобілів,
відповідно вона має свій автопарк.
Коли почався карантин,
ситуація з коронавірусом,
звісно, чим ми могли допомогти —
це своїм транспортом.
Тільки-но закрили метро, ми вже зрозуміли,
ми вже зрозуміли, що треба допомога,
що лікарі не зможуть дістатись на роботу.
І ми почали включатись:
ми впродовж кількох днів
організували свій автомобіль.
[IT-ініціативи]
Всі працюють віддалено, в офісі нікого немає.
Цього місяця придбали п'ять апаратів
штучної вентиляції легень із Німеччини,
і замовили дві тисячі захисних костюмів
для наших лікарів.
Також ми віддали наші офісні 3D-принтери
в одну з майстерень фабрикату,
вони друкують безкоштовні
захисні екрани для лікарів.
На масове тестування на коронавірус
направлений проєкт «United for Health»,
який організований львівським IT-кластером.
Львівський IT-кластер — це асоціація,
яка об'єднує майже 100 IT-компаній у Львові,
і наша компанія є її активним учасником.
Амбітна ціль — провести 100 тисяч тестів
протягом найближчого часу.
Зараз ми закупили 20 тисяч тестів,
також закупляємо наступних 20 тисяч тестів,
інші благочинці закупили
десь таку саму кількість [тестів].
Ми думаємо, що ми дуже скоро
наблизимось до нашої цілі.
Питання, яке торкається кожного в світі,
у тому числі і наших клієнтів.
Тому кожна країна з цією проблемою
зараз сам на сам,
і той, хто більш мобілізований,
хто має більшу здатність до об'єднання,
хто має більшу довіру один до одного —
той і переможе у цій складній ситуації.
Соціально-відповідальний проєкт
розробили портал,
на якому можна швидко відслідковувати потреби,
бізнес може долучатись до цієї ініціативи.
Це веб-портал, який допомагає
консолідуватися бізнесу та волонтерам,
і бути залученими до того,
щоб конвертувати негативні настрої
або паніку в якісь конструктивні дії.
Харківський IT-кластер разом з ком'юніті,
і разом із відповідальними IT-компаніями
стартував проєкт «IT for life».
По-перше, проєкт «IT for life» —
це допомога медичним закладам,
і забезпеченням їх найнеобхіднішим обладнанням
для діагностики та лікування хворих на COVID-19.
Ми об'єднались і створили платформу,
яка отримала назву
«Бізнес Дніпра проти коронавірусу».
Учасниками платформи вже було зібрано
два з половиною мільйона гривень,
на які частково ми закупили
та передали до опорних лікарень
захисні халати, окуляри,
медичні маски, респіратори,
захисні щитки, бахіли, шапочки, антисептики
та декілька кисневих концентраторів
та пульсоксиметрів.
Соціальна ізоляція погано
на всіх нас впливає, це стрес.
До того ж, люди почали
менше довіряти один одному,
і водночас з'явився якийсь зв'язок.
Тобто всі люди зараз пов'язані однією проблемою,
і це всіх єднає.
Зараз найбільш уразливими групами людей
є медичні працівники,
і саме тому наша нова ініціатива «Як» —
це сайт з порадами та інструкціями
щодо того, що і як робити під час пандемії.
Він, у першу чергу, спрямований на людей,
які хочуть захистити себе,
і на ньому також багато інструкцій
для медпрацівників.
[Допомога тим, хто потребує]
Коли я почала розповідати про те,
що я допомагаю бідним,
відгукнулося дуже багато моїх друзів і знайомих,
які почали допомагати мені.
Вони готують обіди, вони пакують,
вони допомагають грошима, одягом
і мені лишається це все лише якось координувати,
і їздити на роздачі.
У цьому, звичайно, є елемент ризику,
тому що на кожній роздачі я контактую
з кількома десятками людей,
про стан здоров'я яких я нічого не знаю.
Я дотримуюся всіх заходів безпеки:
маски, рукавички, перевдягатися,
коли я приходжу додому,
тому що в мене маленькі діти, старі батьки,
і, звичайно, потрібно дуже слідкувати
за своїм станом здоров'я.
Мене звуть Женя Кравченко, мені 31 рік,
і я — співзасновниця ініціативи «Макітра»,
яка розробляє стратегії залучення волонтерів,
членів, людей до громадських організацій.
Знайомтесь. Це Сергій.
Він — наш штатний водій на час,
поки ми організовуємо допомогу людям.
Під час карантину ми об'єдналися
з Українською православною церквою
і небайдужими людьми,
і допомагаємо людям, і сім'ям,
які опинилися в скрутному становищі,
і надаємо їм продукти першої необхідності.
Коли ми допомагаємо іншим,
ми стаємо трішечки,
а то і дуже сильно щасливішими.
А гарний настрій зміцнює імунну систему,
тому ніякого ризику, а навпаки —
ми ще й допомагаємо собі вижити в час кризи.
[сміється]
Це моє робоче місце.
Це мій улюблений куточок,
де я можу спостерігати те,
що відбувається на вулиці,
спостерігати як деякі люди,
наприклад, мають змогу гуляти,
а ми тут працюємо,
і насолоджуємось нашою роботою.
[з телефону]
... активно долучаються до збору.
Я сподіваюсь, цього тижня ми закриємо
проєкт на півтора мільйони гривень.
О! Це буде круто!
Скажи, будь ласка,
а куди буде направлений цей проєкт?
Що вони будуть закупляти?
Там шість лікарень:
Жашків, Чернігівська область ...
Ми будемо закупати пакети крові до Жашкова,
потім захисні костюми,
респіратори та інший захист для лікарів.
— Тобто захист все ж таки?
— Так.
Клас!
Привіт! Мене звати Наталка,
родом я із села Тарасівка Полтавської області,
а останні десять років проживаю у Варшаві.
Українці без кордонів — це діаспорна мережа,
у межах якої зараз я разом зі своїми знайомими
організовуємо збір коштів серед діаспори
на потреби українських лікарів.
І всю свою допомогу ми зосередили
на потребах маленьких лікарень,
тобто ми передаємо допомогу передусім
у малі інфекційні лікарні,
які знаходяться у віддалених районних центрах.
Привіт! Мене звуть Остап Коркуна, мені 32 роки,
а це Марко, йому скоро буде рік, цього місяця.
Я сам — з України.
Я народився і виріс у Львові,
а вже останні десять років живу
постійно в Сан-Франциско, у Каліфорнії.
У 2013 — 2014 роках тут громада в Сан-Франциско
дуже активно підтримувала Майдан,
і як результат цієї підтримки,
разом з кількома однодумцями, волонтерами,
ми заснували неприбуткову організацію,
яку назвали «Нова Юкрейн».
Відтоді ми вже займаємося тут такою волонтерською діяльністю.
Зі спалахом коронавірусної інфекції
в Україні та в усьому світі,
ми почали збирати кошти
для придбання захисного обладнання для лікарів
по лікарнях по всій Україні.
Це рукавички, халати, окуляри, бахіли.
Надзвичайний прогрес, власне,
з фандрайзером від «Нова Юкрейн»:
ми всього за тиждень зібрали більше,
ніж 30 тисяч доларів.
Це 800 плюс донорів,
це валідація і підписання контрактів
із трьома партнерами в Україні.
Наразі ми співпрацюємо з такими містами,
як Львів, Івано-Франківськ та Київ,
але один із наших партнерів —
це «Пацієнти України».
Вони мають волонтерів
і свою мережу по всій Україні,
тому що наша мета —
це допомога у всі регіони України.
[Тестування військових]
Мене звати Олег Карпенко, мені 30 років,
і я працюю в фонді «Повернись живим».
Було визначено,
що ми будемо проводити тестування
визначеної категорії осіб
безпосередньо на лінії зіткнення.
У першому підрозділі за перший день
я з моїм колегою протестували
близько 150 військовослужбовців.
Нами було закуплено захисні костюми,
дезінфікувальні засоби, маски, рукавички.
Після першого етапу тестування,
за даними лабораторії,
не було виявлено жодного позитивного
результату на коронавірус.
Нам, як і в 2014 році,
випала нагода вкотре довести собі,
і довести усьому оточенню,
що ми сильна нація,
і якщо ми будемо зґуртованими,
і відповідальними,
ми зможемо впоратись не тільки з вірусами,
які активно поширюються світом,
а і з Російською Федерацією,
яка вже шостий рік веде активні бойові дії
на сході нашої держави.
Тому мийте руки,
не забувайте про свою армію,
і залишайтесь вдома.
А ми разом із Збройними силами України
зробимо усе необхідне задля вашої безпеки!
Слава Україні!
[Автор
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Ukraїner
на карантині]